thank you for being here and joining me
this afternoon i wanted to provide you a
few important updates as we prepare to
enter 2021
i hope nevadans are finding safe ways to
celebrate the holidays
enjoy time with their families and
reflect back on the difficult year we
have faced together as a state
today i am pleased to be joined once
again by shannon bennett from the
state's immunization program
she will help provide an update
on the rollout for the covet 19 vaccine
and what nevadans can expect to see in
the coming days and months
as we have said from the start this is a
dynamic and fluid situation
and we learn more and more from the
federal government each day
about this vaccine rollout we're being
as transparent as possible
with nevadans during this time before we
get to that update i first want to talk
to nevadans
about the recently signed federal
stimulus package
and how we expect to see that shakeout
in nevada
as many of you know the bill was signed
by the president on sunday
like many nevadans i was glad to see
congress finally reach a compromise to
bring more aid to the americans
as a fight against covet 19 stretches
into 2021
but we know that this is not enough not
for nevada
and not for the country as a whole the
scale of this pandemic is unprecedented
and we need support that matches this
need this is a drop in the bucket
towards putting americans
and our country back on the path towards
stability
i want to thank nevada's federal
delegation for continuing to fight
tirelessly
on behalf of nevadans because of their
advocacy
this latest package includes funding for
priority areas
such as education housing small
businesses
and unemployment i know they will
continue to fight for us in the coming
months when congress and president-elect
biden begin considering
another stimulus package the state team
including the governor's finance office
will continue to evaluate the funding in
the stimulus package
in this current form to determine how
this will affect current programs in
place
especially in light of the cares act
spending deadline being extended
we will continue to work closely with
the federal delegation
as there are more updates now i'd like
to switch gears
a little and talk about the ongoing
rollout of the vaccines in the state of
nevada
i'm proud to report that as of tuesday
25
636 doses of covid19 vaccine
have been administered and reported in
nevada web i z
just last week on a regular planning
call our state team was given kudos
by the centers for disease control on
how well
the initial distribution is going in
nevada
so far we have seen smooth deliveries
the successful rollout of the complex
process
to redistribute vaccine doses across our
great state
and our local health districts and
hospitals immediately went to work
on lining up their folks to get the
vaccine
i'm proud of our state team who work
closely with the federal government and
pharmacy partners
to allocate vaccine doses to long-term
care
and skilled nursing facilities in the
first week
which not all states were able to do
because of that
immunization for skilled nursing
facilities began on december 21st
and vaccination in assisted living
facilities will start
next week as you know these facilities
are home to some of nevada's most
vulnerable populations
and this is a huge step to make sure
they're protected
like so much else in the pandemic this
vaccine rollout is unprecedented
in nature two vaccines that require two
doses
potentially more vaccines being
developed right now
mass distribution on a scale never
before done in our country
all while managing a surge in this
pandemic and working to meet the
historic demand for critical services
the vets need during this tough time
the same team of folks who you've seen
with me discussing the vaccination
rollout
are part of our state team that helps
coordinate testing
data analysis and reporting providing
advice and guidance to the state
hospitals businesses and schools
they now have added the complex
logistical challenge of vaccine
distribution to their plates
and again i'm so proud of our
battle-born team
but states across the country and here
in nevada are stretched thin
i was pleased to see that the latest
stimulus package includes more federal
funding
for the ongoing vaccination rollout and
i was pleased to see president-elect joe
biden pledge
to more provide more support on the
vaccine efforts
when he comes into office i look forward
to that support
and i will work with anyone at any level
to overcome the rest of this terrible
pandemic while
states have been on the front line of
this pandemic for nearly 10 months
this is a national crisis that demands a
unified national strategy
and solution i'm hopeful we're heading
in that direction
at this time i'd like to turn it over to
shannon bennett
immunization program manager in the
division of public and behavioral health
to provide more updates on how the tier
one distribution is going
and our ongoing efforts to update the
state's playbook to match the latest
information
from the cdc
thank you governor it is a pleasure to
be here and provide information on the
vaccine rollout and the playbook update
as of tuesday more than 20 000 doses of
pfizer
and almost 5 000 doses of modern vaccine
have been administered and reported into
nevada
by z the process is going well
and we remain in close contact with all
nevada counties
as the first doses are received and
administered
for both of the vaccine brands currently
in use two doses are required
and the same product must be used for
both doses
this week we ordered the second dose of
the vaccine to be delivered next week
and administers administered to those
who were the first to be immunized in
our state
going forward we will work with
vaccinators to ensure the second dose is
ordered for every dose administered
each week nevada receives an allocation
of covet 19 vaccine from the federal
government
staff assess the allocation against the
need in each county and then work
directly with the counties and local
health authorities to determine
equitable orders for each county for the
upcoming week
we remain in close contact with our
partners statewide to provide guidance
as more information is received from the
federal government
while nevada had the framework of
pandemic influenza
for planning we knew that framework
would have to be adjusted to meet the
needs of coven 19 vaccine response
using available federal guidance the
program has worked hard
to develop a playbook that is specific
to our state
and weighs our vulnerable populations
ethical considerations
unique workforce needs geography and
concerns from partners
and stakeholders the playbook continues
to be fluid
we must remain flexible to ensure a
proper and robust
covin-19 vaccine response
we will continue to apply a data-driven
approach to vaccine allocation
and work with counties to ensure the
playbook and the advisory committee on
immunization practices
recommendations are being followed for
priority populations to be vaccinated
as more doses of the vaccine are
received in nevada and distributed to
counties
some regions of the state may move into
the next tier sooner than others
based on factors such as population size
and vaccine demand
and a tier group as we work
through the first tier of vaccination
nevada's medical workforce are able to
receive
the vaccine and our pharmacy partners
are working to vaccinate staff
and residents in nevada's long-term care
facilities
our pharmacy partners are diligently
testing their staff to ensure
vaccinating pharmacists are covered
negative before entering the facilities
to provide vaccinations
we have heard from many facilities
across our state
that this program is working well
in addition to long-term care facility
staff and residents the immunization
program
has worked with the state aging and
disability services division
to identify intensive supported living
arrangements and supported living
arrangement facilities
for staff and residents to ensure these
populations are also included in tier 1.
we are finalizing the updated vaccine
playbook to include the most recent cdc
recommendations
information for clinicians more details
on individual populations
and guidance related to the specific
recommended vaccines
however prior to the roll out of the
completed updates i wanted to provide
you all with some decisions that have
been made as of today
nevada's tiered structure has been
updated to include prioritization of
people 75 and
older in tier 2 or what the cdc
refers to as phase 1b
these nevadans will be vaccinated
concurrently with the first group of
nevada's frontline essential workers
the list of tier 2 frontline essential
workers is not
will not vary greatly from the current
playbook but further updates will be
provided in the full rollout
upon final review and conversations with
stakeholders additionally those 65 to 74
years
years of age and people with underlying
health conditions will be vaccinated in
tier 3
alongside nevada's second group of
essential workers
similar to tier two the essential
workers in tier three
will remain will largely remain the same
as those listed in the current playbook
with some adjustments that will be
provided to the public in the full
rollout
this playbook is a guide that we know
will be adjusted as more information is
learned and the
vaccination rollout progresses across
the united states
we continue to have a limited supply of
vaccine and are working with
organizations statewide to provide
information on the tiers
and prioritization of those unable to
work from home
and those most likely to come into
contact with cobin 19 patients
i will now turn it back over to governor
sisilak thank you
thank you shannon i know your team
continues to adjust as necessary
as nevada moves through the response to
meet the needs of our state
and i think it's important for nevadans
to know that during the time period
when coved vaccines are limited the
allocation is based on
scientific data key ethical principles
federal recommendations now unique
implementation challenges
above all else our state playbook is
designed to mitigate as much disease
spread
and loss of life as possible i know
nevadans will continue to have questions
related to vaccine distributions
and our goal is to provide updates as
frequently as possible
we are working on some exciting new ways
to communicate this information
to you and look forward to rolling those
out in
the near future in the meantime we're
going to remain flexible so we can
adjust the new federal recommendations
local considerations vaccine supply
updates and much more
i want to again thank you and the entire
team for their tireless work on this
vaccination roll-up plan
this rollout is unlike any other and i
am proud of the work you continue to do
to help prepare and educate nevadans
for this before we conclude i want to
remind nevadans
that while we are working on
distributing vaccines as fast as we can
covid19 is still very much with us
we must all take the proper mitigation
measures to slow the spread of this
virus
please stay home if you can especially
if you feel sick
wear your mask at all times when around
people not in your household
avoid large crowds and practice social
distancing
wash your hands frequently we have all a
lot we've all got a lot of work to do
it will take all of us to recommit
ourselves to turning things around
before a vaccine is widely available
earlier this week dr fauci said that
january
may be worse than december in terms of
the coronavirus
our actions now can help prevent that
but we must all
do it together after a historically
difficult year we have so much to look
forward to in 2021
but we must commit to doing all we can
to stay safe
to make it to those better days together
vaccinations are already being
distributed to our healthcare workers in
nevada
but it will take time to get to the
point of full-scale vaccination
of all residents until then we must
double down on staying safe to make it
through
this is the way we come back stronger
and require
recover faster in 2021
it's not lost on me that las vegas is
known for being one of the best places
in the world to ring in the new year
but this year we must look different
i know people want to celebrate the end
of 2020
and i don't blame them but if we don't
start making smart choices
at the start of 2021 we will look a lot
and feel a lot more like 2020 than any
of us want it to be
we must protect ourselves and each other
now
by avoiding high risk activities that
includes
gathering in large crowds i'm counting
on responsible resort
restaurant and business owners to
strictly
follow the state's directives and i
strongly urge anyone in a public setting
to follow all of our life-saving
guidelines if you're considering going
out
i urge you to reconsider and think of
nevada's healthcare workers
who will be caring for covet-19 patients
our family members
and neighbors who are struggling to
breathe and make it through the night
they've been providing this care under
the most difficult of circumstances for
10 months now
and they are asking for our help have
their backs the way they have
ours celebrate new year's virtually at
home
with your household members additionally
to stress the importance of taking all
safety measures seriously in the coming
days and weeks
i want to share the updates and
recommendations provided to nevada
this week from the house task force
nevada is currently ranked eighth
nationally in new cases
for a hundred thousand people we're
ranked second nationally in test
positivity right
and 17th in admissions per 100 hospital
beds
this is serious folks we don't need to
look far to see what it looks like when
hospitals are overwhelmed
we must do all we can to prevent that
from happening in our state
so please please adhere to the following
recommendations
from the white house if you are over 65
or with significant health conditions
you should not
enter any indoor public spaces where
anyone
is unmasked due to the immediate risk to
your health
you should have your groceries and
medications delivered
no unmasked public gatherings are safe
and no
indoor private gatherings are safe
without all members fully masked
unless all members are actively taking
the same precautions and regularly
testing negative
all states with continued increases that
includes us
must continue with strict public
mitigation and continued restrictions
the current restrictions under the
statewide pause
which impose strict limits on capacity
and gathering sizes
are still in place and there are no
exceptions for these mitigation
requirements
on new year's eve covent 19 is not going
to take the night off to ring in the new
year
safety is a partnership and everyone has
a role to play
i am asking all individuals to avoid
large gatherings
i'm asking our workers to practice all
precautions
i'm asking our businesses and local
governments to enforce
all the rules i'm asking that our
visitors respect our efforts to keep you
and our employees safe the state
enforcement authorities will be out in
force
on new year's eve to ensure measures are
being followed
including the gaming control board
additionally
local governments have committed to
being partners in all enforcement
efforts many times over the past month
and i'm hopeful they will use their
resources to assist in making sure
all public health measures are followed
let's all do the best we can to protect
ourselves and each other
because i believe that 2021 will be
nevada's greatest
comeback story ever and i want all
nevadans to be part of it
i'm confident we have many great reasons
to have the greatest new year
celebration ever
next january 1st i wish you all the
safest end of 2020 possible
stay well stay safe and stay healthy
believe in yourself and believe in
nevada thank you
at this time my staff will coordinate
questions
megan thank you governor this is megan
delaney governor says flex
communications director
um again we'll use the raised hand
function to coordinate the q a here so
if you're a media member
on the zoom with us you could use the
raised hand and then i'll call on you so
governor will go to the first question
it's bill denzer from the rj bill you
can unmute and ask the governor your
question
hi governor hi shannon thanks for doing
this
the the playbook has a section on the
communications plan for the vaccination
program
and we've been getting and i'm sure
other media have as well
a lot of questions from people who don't
or who aren't getting this information
as timely as possible are you
at this point um satisfied with how
communication is going
uh can it be improved what other
vehicles besides
these press conferences are being used
right now to get word out to
average folk well uh we're always
looking to improve it and always a lot
more can be done but
shannon if you want to jump in on that
one
thank you governor thank you for the
question um yes
we will be enhancing our communication
strategies throughout the weeks and
months ahead
with specific focus on those people that
we're trying to reach so we can look
forward in the coming weeks um
to messaging specifically for our 75 and
older nevadans
and then our frontline essential workers
if i could just follow up briefly uh
does the state anticipate any changes
outside of the continued cdc uh
recommended uh recommended changes
nevada is every state is unique but
nevada is particularly
unique we will take all the factors into
account
our workforce our economy uh
our aged population and so forth but we
will definitely use cdc guidelines
but they'll we will also flavor that
with local
guidelines thank you thanks governor
thanks bill we'll go to the next
question we'll take lauren martinez from
fox
5 as the next question after lauren will
do sam metz from the ap
lauren it looks like your microphone's
unmuted but i'm not able to hear you can
you try again
hello
hello okay we've got you now lauren go
ahead
okay uh governor i have a question
regarding our seniors
um you mentioned that those that are 65
and up
are at risk but we're seeing other
states like florida
and texas vaccinating um
this this age group so why not bump them
up
higher well it would in an ideal world
we'd like to bump everybody up higher
and i'll let shannon go after this
our immediate need our immediate number
one on stage
tier one was our front line healthcare
workers and those that are confined to
nursing home facilities and skilled
nursing facilities but shannon go ahead
thank you governor and thank you for the
question um we will be following
cdc's advisory committee on immunization
practice framework and they recommend
75 and older to be included in that
phase 1b or nevada's tier 2.
the reason that they are recommending
that is because we see a higher
mortality rate especially with those 75
and older
thank you shannon thank you governor
thank you lauren for the question i know
there's a
new version of the playbook that we're
working on so we'll have that all
spelled out there
i think i said we would take sam that's
next um and then we'll do riley snyder
from the indy after sam hi thanks for
taking my question
governor sislek and ms bennett you both
said we vaccinated about
25 000 people thus far i don't have the
exact number but i believe that's less
than 20 percent of our initial allotment
why aren't more shots in people's arms
and this is similar to lauren's question
shannon you talked about concurrent
tears states like colorado and texas and
florida have revised their tears
contrary to cdc guidelines
to vaccinate older people more quickly
shannon
you talked about concurrent tears would
we ever do something
like those states are doing
shannon go ahead thank you governor
uh thank you for the question um the
the doses that we are seeing
administered into nevada web i z
are likely lagging behind the doses that
are truly been administered it is a
large lift
to put doses administered enter doses
administered into
the nevada webiz system and these
vaccinators in our local community that
would be responsible for
inputting that data into nevada web ic
are also
managing the storage and handling of a
new vaccine and
the logistics of these vaccination
events so i think
what we're seeing is simply a data lag
there and
um to answer your other piece to the
question we will be following
the advisory committee on immunization
practice guidance from the cdc
thank you clarify to fact check do we
know how many
uh vaccines we've been allocated how
many we've
received so we can calculate a
percentage of
shots and arms over initial allocation
i think sam what you're not
understanding is we know what
is being delivered i don't have that in
front of me but there's a lag
in the time frame from when the dose is
actually administered
to when it is entered into the web iz
program so it wouldn't give you a valid
number
so we're spending more time vaccinating
than we are data inputting at this time
sam we can follow up with you to make
sure you have um that information
uh riley snyder from the indy next and
then brian
hoffman from ktvn
great uh thank you so much governor and
janet for taking the question i wanted
to ask is there any plan
to include members of the state
legislature in the vaccination
tier list by the time they meet in
february is that
in the cards or part of the playbook at
all well we'll be coming out with the
whole playbook to plan next week
or the week after so it'll be prior to
the legislative session
but it's a difficult balancing act
raleigh to take people that everyone
that's in need those with underlying
conditions
some of those in the legislature will
also follow into another group
that they would have priority on so
we're gonna have to wait and see in
terms of what the final recommendations
coming out of the
cdc and our own committee are
thank you riley thank you governor we'll
go to brian hoffman for the next
question
and then after brian we'll do joe
bartels
excellent thank you so much and thank
you so much for doing this governor i
was wondering if
we can uh get a location for the amount
of people
that have been vaccinated so far and if
we're going to be updating that
daily weekly monthly i know there is
that delay but
seeing those numbers rise might give
some people some hope
would we be able to have access to that
in the future
shannon what is the plan for that
we are currently assessing ways to share
data more frequently
thank you governor thank you brian for
the question um i think one to be as
transparent
as we can with this information the
problem is we don't want to get
tied up in the reporting part of it
where we're spending more time providing
reports
and having people input information as
opposed to
administering the actual vaccine so
we're trying to balance all of that and
we'll come up with a better
uh situation in the future
thank you governor sorry for cutting you
off there we'll go joe to the next
question
and then i think i have sasha from klas
so joe and then sasha please
thank you megan thank you governor for
taking my uh my question here uh covet
19 task force met
yesterday they were scratching their
heads regarding the fremont street
gathering
clark county chairwoman marilyn
kirkpatrick warned hospitals could be
overrun if this gathering were to go
forward she also said that she'd be
asking
for that reduction in the gathering to 7
000 people that's well over the
50-person limit there was issues of the
first amendment versus public health
were being thrown out as possible
reasons as to why this should go forward
governor i was just thinking i was
wondering what your thoughts are on this
well look i've not pulled any punches
with anybody
this is a tough balancing act it's been
a tough balancing act since june
when we started opening back up i've
been upfront about how difficult this is
we've made adjustments along the way
we're now in this pause
our decisions are grounded in how we can
keep as many people
say as safe as possible while keeping as
many jobs going
as possible allowing families to pay
their bills
keep their homes feed their kids but
with the balance comes a great
responsibility for everyone in the state
to do what they can to be safe
i've been very clear this whole time
about the importance of masking
social distancing and gathering of
people it's on
every individual every local government
and every
business to do their part and to take
this seriously
there's no secret formula there's no
secret sauce
at this stage in the game we know what
is considered a high-risk activity
and large gatherings are included in
high-risk activities
i understand that on new year's eve
particularly in las vegas
it'll be difficult to prevent the
organic gatherings of people
and that's why it's critical that
businesses and leaders are vocal about
the risks
but to organize and promote a gathering
with a ticket
or a fee as if it's a business business
as usual
that's just plain irresponsible the
virus doesn't care about these
definitions these loopholes
call it a gathering an assembly the
science prevails
and the science says that the more
people in the gathering
it's guaranteed that a portion are going
to have covet
either symptomatic or asymptomatic and
they will spread that disease
the larger the group of people the not
larger the number that will get sick
of those a percentage will end up in our
already overwhelmed hospitals
and sadly a percentage of those will die
that's why we limited the organized
gatherings
thank you governor thank you joe for the
question we'll go to sasha next and then
um gerard will do next question after
sasha there
oh hi governor thank you for taking my
question uh regarding the statewide
pause i know we've been
in this pause for uh quite a few weeks
now i know our
uh our positivity rate is still higher
than we'd like it to be but it has
dipped slightly
is there evidence this is you know
working this is it
uh stopping the spread of covet 19 to a
point
or what data do we have on that if there
is any well i'm sure that you follow our
numbers as closely as i do
follow our numbers and we see it kind of
ticking up and ticking down
we're just a couple days out from the
christmas holiday
and hanukkah and you saw that travel was
exceedingly high across the country
over christmas we're going into new
year's eve tomorrow
and we're going to see how that plays
out that's why we went to january 15th
to see what the
uh impact of these couple holidays are
going to do
large gatherings as i said in the
previous answer aren't going to help
they're not going to minimize the spread
they're going to make the condition
worse and
worse and they're going to make it more
difficult for health care workers so
where we're going to be on january 15th
is going to need to be dependent
on how seriously we take these measures
now
thank you governor thank you sasha for
the question i have two more folks with
hand raised that's gerard and brett
forrest
so we can go through those two questions
please gerard
yes governor thank you for your time my
question has
to do with respect to the
violations that may or may not occur on
new year's eve
um is there going to be more policing of
of some of these gatherings and some of
these um
restaurants and clubs and things like
that we've checked around and
all of them seem to be at capacity i
know you're not supposed to be
advertising a new year's eve event
but most of them have some sort of
special
and you have to pre-purchase this
and um obviously there are limits but
there's probably a good chance that a
lot of these limits are going to be
violated is there any special policing
order that you have in place
well i'm hopeful that all these limits
aren't going to be violated
on new year's eve as i said previously
it's up to the businesses to enforce the
regulations are in place it's up to the
citizens the patronized businesses that
enforce the regulations
and it's important that they keep their
employees and their customers safe
i can tell you that uh gaming
enforcement division is going to be out
in full force tomorrow
the various business license entities
and
response units and the counties in the
cities are going to be out osha is going
to be out so we're going to have
full-fledged enforcement available this
isn't an idea of
playing gotcha or a loophole or take
advantage of the night and make money
it's not worth it to take advantage of
the night and try to make a few extra
bucks and i know everybody's struggling
when i say this i know everybody's
struggling if you think about the
potential
impact of a breakout at an event at a
restaurant
at a bar at a facility and what the end
ramifications can be of that so
we're asking everybody to do their part
to follow their recommendations
if everybody does their part i'm
confident we'll come out okay
thank you governor thank you for the
question the last question i have um is
from brett forest so brett you can
unmute and ask the governor your
question
or shannon all right thank you yeah
brett force of news 4 here
uh could you clarify which tier that 75
and older group now falls under and also
is there any concern for the
supply chain delay of the second booster
shock and to people who already received
their first dose of the vaccine
thank you for your question thank you
for your question
um so the 75 and older population will
be vaccinated concurrently with
frontline essential workers in tier two
um and i do not have any concerns about
the second dose
um we are already well into
our orders to get that delivered next
week for administration for all of those
who received their their doses that very
first week
great thank you for the question thank
you for that answer shannon i don't have
any more questions
in the queue here so governor if you
have any closing remarks before we end
today
thank you megan i appreciate it i
appreciate everybody for tuning in
and listening and watching today i'm
going to wish you all a very
happy 2021 kathy and i and my family
all wish you have a happy and healthy
and safe year but a lot of what happens
in 2021 is going to depend on how we end
2020 and i ask you to please do your
part
practice the protocols wearing a mask
social distancing
avoid large gatherings wash your hands
if everybody does their part
i'm confident we can have a safe healthy
and happy new year and great 2021 as we
come out of this coronavirus pandemic
and get back to the nevada that we all
know and love so thank you all very much
everyone